الينا الان من بيروت لويس ميجال بيونير
المتحدث باسم الاتحاد الاوروبي ومن كياف
ايفانا كليمبوش رئيسه لجنه التكامل
الاوروبيه في البرلمان الاوكراني ونائبه
رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني سابقا اهلا بضيفين
نبدا من بيروت والسيد بيونو هل هل الوقت
فعلا مناسب لبحث موضوع
بدء انضمام اوكرانيا الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
المستمر لاوكرانيا للشعب الاوكراني خلال
هذه الفتره صعبه لتمر بها اوكرانيا طبعا
نحن سنوساعد وسنقدم كل ما لدينا من
ادواتنا لاوكرانيا لاستكمال هذه العمليه
وقت ممكن اشرت الى كل كلمه شروط وعاده هذه
الشروط للانضمام تطول وهناك دول تعرفها
بالتاكيد تنتظر الان منذ سنوات هل سيكون
هذا هو مصير اوكرانيا ايضا
طبعا الشروط موجوده بالفعل يعني السلطات
الاوكرانيه تدرك ذلك
وتعامل على استعمال الاصلاحات واجراء هذا
المساحات اللازمه مرتبطه بما يسمى
الاوبينيون او التقرير الساده العام
المفضل الاوروبيه قبل شهور اللي هي تتعلق
بالساحات يعني مثلا تعديل المحكمه القانون
المتعلق بما الدستوريه يعني تعيين القضاء
مكافحه الفساد وما الى ذلك هناك سلاحات
معروفه وبنفس الوقت يعني من الرئه ان نكون
يعني ان نشهد بالفعل ان هناك دوله عسكريه
لها وفي نفس الوقت تستطيع اجداح هذا
الاجراءات وهذا الاصلاحات بشكل يعني ناجح
كبير جدا يعني نحن يعني نشد قدره اوكرانيا
بهذا المجال بالفعل ومره اخرى اعتقد انه
هناك اجماع في مجلس الاتحاد الاوروبي حول
ضروره مواصله هذا الدعم لاوكرانيا
مفاوضات حول انضمامها للاتحاد
اهلا وسهلا بك هل لديك
ثقه في ان هذا المسار سيتوج فعلا في
القريب بالانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
انا ليس لدي اي توقع اخر ان اوكرانيا
ستصبح عضوا في الاتحاد الاوروبي انا ايضا
اعتقد ان اوكرانيا ستصبح ايضا عضوا في
النيتو وهذا موقف فريد من نوعه اننا في
هذه الحرب الصعبه الاصعب التي راتها
القاره الاوروبيه منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه نحن نخوض في هذه الحرب لكننا نركز
في نفس الوقت على اجراء تحول ايجابي في
البلد بالتالي هذه امر في غايه الاهميه
وهو يعكس الرغبه والحلم رغبه الشعب
الاوكراني ووجود مثل هذه الفرصه التاريخيه
في ان نكون دوله مرشحه نحن نعمل بجهد من
اجل تحقيق هذا الهدف والانتقال الى الخطوه
الثانيه الثانيه في مساله مفاوضات العضويه
مثل ما اشار السيد بيونو
لاول مره دوله في حاله حرب تطلب الانضمام
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي الا يخيفكم ذلك
بمعنى ان الاتحاد سيكون متحفظا نوعا ما
لانه يرث عبء ثقيلا على الصعيد الاقتصادي
واعاده الاعمار وغير ذلك
والنقطه الاهم اننا نقدر موقف الاتحاد
الاوروبي اننا نحارب اليوم
دفاعا عن القيم
حقوق الانسان والمبادئ الديمقراطيه وهي
العمود الفقري للاتحاد الاوروبي بالتالي
لدينا الكثير من النقاط التي مشتركه وايضا
نرى مستقبلنا سويه
بالتالي من المفهوم انه سيكون هنالك ربما
عواقب جديه بعد هذه الحرب لان روسيا تحاول
ان تمحين عن خارطه العالم وتحاول ان تدمر
كل شيء يمر في طريقها لكن هذا لا يعني ان
هذا قد يمثل عبئا اعتقد ان من المهم انه
يمثل ان يمثل فرصه مهمه للجميع من اجل
اعاده انعاش مال نؤمن به والنضمن
ان الديكتاتوريات
والحكام المستبدين لا يقومون بمهاجمه
بلداننا وان لا تسود قوتهم على قوه
القانون وعلى حق الانسان بالعيش السيد
بيونو الوضع الاستثنائي لاوكرانيا في طلب
الانضمام هل يشجع الاتحاد الاوروبي على
التعجيل في الاجراءات وربما حتى التخفيف
من بعض الشروط
اعتقد انه العكس هو صحيح نحن راينا هذا
الاعظم يعني هذا الاراده الحقيقيه لذا ليس
فقط السلطات الاوكرانيه وانما الشعب
الاوكراني عموما باتجاه هذه العمليه عمليه
انضمامه في الاتحاد الاوروبي ويعني
بخطوات سريعه وافعاله وملموسه جدا خلال
شهور الماضيه مرتبطه بهذه العمليه
اعتقد انه صحيح يعني هناك من قبل الاتحاد
الاوروبي من قبل اوكرانيا الرقبه مشتركه
للمزيد من التعاون حول يعني هذا الامر
اجراء هذه لصاحات اللازمه وبدا المفوضات
ولكن طبعا نتحدث عن 35 بندا حول يعني
الاقابل الانضمام الرسمي الذي حضر فيه
ولكن يعني اريد النشيد لنقطه اساسيه اللي
هي طبعا انه نحن نمر بفتره استثمانيه جدا
في القرار الروبيه ومره اخرى التضامن
الروبي للتجاره الاوكراني غير موجود فقط
على مستوى ق ولكن ايضا على الشعر الفراغ
المستوى شارع الاوروبيه كذلك شكرا جزيلا
لك السيد
شكرا لك سيده ايفانا